This is the thing I don't think I don't,
fighting is very important to me.
It means a lot.
It means a lot because I used to do it.
It means a lot cause I love to watch it.
It means a lot because I'm very deeply
entrenched in the history and the
significance of it, what
it means. And for me,
fighting should always
be done at its best.
And what that means is you should always
do what's the right thing to do in the
situation. Like if you're, uh, you know,
you could break it down when
individual arts, right? If you're, um,
if you're doing Jujitsu,
there's a,
there's a correct way to do
an arm bar counter, right?
Don't do the incorrect way because
the fans want to see, right.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
If there's an exciting way
to get out of an arm bar,
that's not the right way to do it. But not
Dan's like his lamb, but it might, well,
the pick 'em up and slam.
I'm works if you have to,
but I'm saying like just as
a rough example, if, if you,
if there was a way to defend an arm bar
that wasn't the correct way to do it,
but the fans liked it more.
Don't do that. Don't do that.
You want to fight like a maestro, right?
You want to fight like, like a virtuoso.
You want to fight like mighty mouse. There
you go. Exactly. What I tell everybody,
you look at my mighty mouse
has had moments in his career,
like the Ian Mccall fight is
a good example where he was,
he also had a full time job,
wasn't dedicated the way it should be and
got into a brawl and Ian took his back.
Wanna pounded them and mighty mouse
had vertigo. After that fight,
he was really fucked up and,
and then quit his job.
I realize like I have to go full time.
I have to dedicate myself to this full
time, you know? And when he did that,
then under the tutelage of Matt Hume,
he came,
he became the mighty mouse we see now.
But in my opinion,
one of the things that sets him
apart from everybody else is that he,
he's not running away from
you and not getting hit.
He's running at you and
not getting hit or, I mean,
he's coming straight forward and then
cutting angles and doing things to you
that you didn't anticipate and
he's not there for the counters.
So he's fighting correctly.
Seamless too. Yeah.
And it's incredibly exciting.
And that was one of the, the,
the criticisms of him really early on in
his reign was that he wasn't finishing
guys and then he knocked out
Joseph Benevidez and then
he started finishing guys
in the final seconds of the round.
Right. You know what I mean? He's,
he's just a monster man as man.
He says fucking monster.
But he fights correctly.
I would say don't,
no disrespect to Chris Lytle,
who I love. He's a great fighter.
I was just watching his fight against
Brian Foster and he was so skilled that
people have got a good, Chris Lidell
was won that fight with a leg lock. Hmm.
You know, and he's known as a brawler and
people forget, he fucking spun around,
got that leg and snatch it out and
extended and really fuck Brian's leg up
crafty veteran. He was a
crafty guy, but broad a lot.
I'm not a fan of, I'm a fan of
watching brawls when they take place.
I'm not a fan as well either.